so i love me a good sibling dynamic in a
movie because i'm very very close with
my sister and the most important thing
when establishing that is having a good
scene partner so can each of you tell me
something about the other that you
really appreciated in them as a scene
partner that made all the difference for
you on set i
felt like
she really comforted me like
just like
it's not something where usually you
just click with someone this quick or
even have to play siblings with someone
and you just get with them so quickly
it's like let me see how you really act
in and out of it like she
on set and offset she always comforted
me she always made sure i was okay and
she was really a best sister to me
and i love her so much which made me
really be comfortable on set like if i
mess up they won't be like oh my god we
have to restart over again she was like
just it's okay you know you're good
messing up one of those long winners i
imagine has to be very scary
yeah
and for me like we hung out outside of
the set a lot too so like we became like
she said almost real sisters so when
we're acting and doing our scenes it
didn't really feel like acting it just
felt like i was protecting my little
sister and trying to comfort her as she
said so i think that made it it made the
connection even better you feel it you
feel it while you're watching it all
right some individual questions now
first for you leah i am very curious
about your experience working with so
much vfx in this movie because you're
also working on a new show with heavy
vfx so is there anything you learned
about working with vfx on beast that you
find influencing your work on percy
jackson well i learned about this thing
called continuity which means that
everything has to be in the exact same
place so
like we could film something one day
and i stop in this place or have
something like this that means that i
can film it like two months later and i
have to be exactly like that i've
learned to now
know exactly what place what this what
what thing i have to be like
and um
it's really fun i know they have to take
a lot of pictures and like sending in
different types of weird things so but
it was fun though it wasn't something
that's super hard or anything okay i'm
glad you're enjoying it i know for you i
feel bad asking this question because it
feels like a big one with no simple
answer to it but the vfx and the thrills
of this movie are very very important
but her relationship with her father and
how it evolves is like really a big part
of the beating heart of the movie so
what can you do on your end to emphasize
how that relationship is changing but
while being in the midst of a really
exhilarating thrilling scene i think
that it's just a lot for me or my
character that i play and i mean you
just see the journey throughout it and
how they try to figure it out for the
common goal of survival so
it comes through very well it comes
through in that light you know all right
i'm wrapping up with a game for you too
it's one of my favorites so i'm gonna
throw the cast of beast in the middle of
a zombie outbreak so i'll set the scene
for you you are on set filming a day of
this movie and all of a sudden there are
zombies out there i'm gonna give you a
zombie movie cliche and you need to tell
me which actor from the cast best suits
this role okay so first one i have for
you is who is the most likely to be the
last person to catch on and not even
realize there are zombies on set uncle
martin
it was a shout out
yeah
yeah i feel like we'll be so focused
that he'll be like we're gonna be like
mine there's zombies and he's gonna be
like what's happening oh i didn't even
know that i pressed the gas i don't know
i feel like i could see charlton doing
that he's so focused on the work it
makes sense exactly yeah all right who
from the cast is the most likely to
sacrifice themselves for the others
i would say
our dad
yes absolutely he'll do anything to
protect his girls you two can throw each
other under the bus with us too that's
fine
here's here's one who is most likely to
trip and fall while running from the
zombies
oh
sorry definitely it would definitely be
her for sure
no i should be so focused on something
else the next thing you know just fall
in mud or whatever well me and my
brother we run into track and we have to
go over these hurdles so whatever i see
i'm like i gotta make sure what we built
your bubble stuff i feel like it'll be
both of us though at the same time trip
more times how about that
one of you tristan takes the other down
with you yeah i am clumsy boxing the
perfect sibling dynamic all right i'll
end on
this one who is the most likely to get
bit by a zombie and then try to hide
their infection
you could take this in a million
different directions
i feel like it would be me
why
because
in real life like if i get scratched up
or something like i usually try to hide
it that way people don't think that like
something bad happened but also if
something happened to me
and i get like scratched by a zombie
that would be cool walking around like
oh yeah no i'm okay i got it i'm good
like you know be that fierce person
instead of getting help by the way
though but i think it would be our dad
though because he would do anything to
like hide pain and stuff like that so
that yeah we're okay so that's that'll
be my answer that's the thing you can
either hide it because you're afraid
people will know and they'll have to
take you out because you're going to
turn into a zombie or they'll want to
hide it so they could stay longer and
protect you i never know which way
people are going to go with that one i
will be the first way i feel like that
way it won't throw me
i love it congratulations thank you for
your time today
you